Me Never forget where you come from.
Always,
always pay homage to it.
I always pay homage to it.
Never stare because then you end up
there or you end up back there.
But just pay respect and be grateful for
where you came from.
Always.
You know,
I show up and walk every single day like
I'm not in the position.
I mean like I'm not me.
So that's the mindset I have and it's
woven.
It's give,
it gives inspiration to young kids and
young people are anyone any walk of life
to go and achieve things that are deemed
on thinkable and impossible.
That's such a great thing that I'm so
proud of.
So people have dealt with me my hallway
and this has been a bit more
intensified,
the doubt and criticism.
So I'm just going to relish in it.
You know,
the aim is to try to prove myself,
my supporters and my fans and the people
that were with me prove them correct.
And then the second aim is to prove that
that was wrong.
I'm in no hurry to,
you know,
I know my worth and many times have I
said I'm going to do something and I go
and do it.
It wouldn't be the first time.
It certainly won't be the last.
I'm not quite sure what to say about me.
I'm just saying they're probably just
say I'm A.
I'm a young kid.
Showed up when he said he was going to
show.
Well,
I just know that it will live on.
That's what I do know.
I cannot control what people say about
me now or in the future,
but I certainly know what I am doing on
the stuff that I've done and achieved
will live on long after I'm gone.